the European Union and Switzerland are
neighbors and natural Partners we share
not only geography but also values and
close economic links so I'm delighted
that we have reached a common
understanding on a broad and balanced
package of measures that will allow us
to take our relationship forward closer
ties will benefit our citizens and our
businesses on both sides our common
understanding comes after 18 months of
exploratory talks on the future of our
bilateral relationship it allow us to
agree on the key elements that we wanted
to improve I welcome today's decision by
the federal Council to launch
consultations with the Swiss Parliament
and the cantons on a negotiating mandate
for a package of agreements between the
European Union and Switzerland I'm
pleased to announce that the European
commission will mirror this decision in
the coming Days by proposing a draft
mandate for negotiations to the Council
of the European Union fully in line with
our common understanding this is an
important step for the relationship
between the European Union and
Switzerland we end 2023 with encouraging
momentum and I look forward to the next
steps in 2024 once we have both the
necessary mandates to start negotiations
on this promising
agreement